القمح
اساس نظامنا الغذائي بلا منازع
[موسيقى]
اهميته الفائقه تتيح استخدامه كسلاح يقلب
الموازين
[موسيقى]
تعد اوكرانيا من اهم الدول المنتجه
والمصدره للقمح حول العالم
قبل الحرب كان المزارعون الاوكرانيون
يوفرون للعالم اكثر من خمسه ملايين طن من
القمح شهريا
ضه
من الحبوب عالقه في اوكرانيا وهي ثالث
حصاد من العام الماضي
يشهدون لمنعنا من نثر البذور
ويفجرون المستودعات التي تحتوي على الديزل
والبنزين
[موسيقى]
هذا كان سيصبح خبزا
الخيار الوحيد هو اخراج الحبوب من
اوكرانيا عبر ميناء البحر الاسود
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حاليا هذا الحصاد مكلف للغايه فهم قبل كل
شيء يخاطرون بحياتهم من خلال العمل في
الحقول
[موسيقى]
لقد اشترينا معدات مخصصه لهذا الغرض
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا تطالب نتائجها
وتداعياتها العالم باسره النتيجه الاكثر
ماساويه هي نقص الغذاء وهو هذه المره لا
يميز بين غني وفقير
[موسيقى]
الرابع والعشرون من فبراير 2022
اعلنت روسيا بدء عمليه عسكريه ضد اوكرانيا
انها بدايه حرب قد تغير تداعياتها مستقبل
العالم
[موسيقى]
في المره الاخيره قصفت الحقول
ومنطقه الحصاد
قصفت المنطقه باكملها
اعتقد ان هذه الحرب ماساه كبرى
[موسيقى]
هذه حرب يستخدم فيها الطعام كسلاح
جيوسياسي
انه اعلان حرب على الامن الغذائي العالمي
سيكون لها تداعيات غير عاديه
[موسيقى]
ايا كان من يسيطر على صادرات الحبوب في
العالم فسيملك القوه
[موسيقى]
ثلث صادرات العالم من القمح ياتي من روسيا
واوكرانيا
فيما ياتي ثلاث كميه بذور عباد الشمس وزيت
عباد الشمس من اوكرانيا
يعتمد الاقتصاد الاوكراني على الزراعه
ويعيش ما يقرب من ثلث السكان في المناطق
الريفيه
[موسيقى]
في العام الماضي سجل حصادنا رقما غير
مسبوق في التاريخ
180 طن تم تصدير 75% منها في مارس لم
نتمكن من تصدير اكثر من 200 الف طن من
المنتجات الزراعيه قبل الرابع والعشرين من
فبراير 2022 تم الاعلان عن تصدير حوالي
خمسه الى سته ملايين طن يمكنك ان ترى
الفرق هنا بين 200 الف طن وخمسه الى سته
ملايين طن
معظم صادرات القمح يذهب الى البلدان
الناميه غير القادره على انتاج تلك الحبوب
بنفسها وهي البلدان التي تشكل هذه الحبوب
مواد غذائيه ومكونات اساسيه في اطباقها
التقليديه
خاصه لقربها من البحر الاسود رحله سفينه
الشحن القادمه عبر الاطلسي تستغرق شهرين
فيما القدوم من البحر الاسود يستغرق عشره
ايام
افكر مثلا في لبنان الذي ينتظر الحبوب
بامل كبير وقلق اكبر
تسعين في المئه من احتياجاته الغذائيه
قرابه 30% منها ياتي من البحر الاسود الان
مع ارتفاع الاسعار يزداد عدد الاشخاص
الذين يعانون من نقص الغذاء هناك 16 مليون
شخص في اليمن لا يستطيعون الحصول على
كفاياتهم من الطعام
واجهنا عاصفه قبل الحرب الاوكرانيه كورونا
والمناخ ارتفعت اعداد منهم على حافه
المجاعه من 135 مليونا الى 276 مليونا قبل
الحرب على اوكرانيا
هذا العدد غير مرشح للانخفاض بالنظر لكثره
الاضطرابات المتواصله في سلاسل التوريد
والتي كانت مرتبطه اساسا بالجائحه فضلا عن
الجفاف الشديد والان نحن ندخل عامنا
الثالث مع ظاهره النيليا المناخيه في
امريكا الجنوبيه وتحديدا في البرازيل
والارجنتين المصدرين الكبيرين للسكر
والحبوب نحن نواجه اذا مجموعه من الازمات
والاحداث التي تساهم مع الحرب في اوكرانيا
في تعاظم قلق الكثير من المنظمات غير
الحكوميه من تزايد انعدام الامن الغذائي
العالمي
يواجه اسوا ازمه غذائيه منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
[موسيقى]
سنويا يموت حوالي تسعه ملايين شخص من
الجوع من بينهم اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين
الطفل
مشهد يفطر القلب
الهند باكستان ايران لبنان اليمن افريقيا
باكملها
الملايين والملايين من الجياع
لا موارد من اين ستاتي الاموال هل ستطعم
الاطفال في اوكرانيا على حساب الاطفال في
اثيوبيا هل تاخذ الطعام الاطفال الافغان
الى الاطفال في اليمن اتطلب مني ان اختار
اي من الاطفال سيعيش واي منهم سيموت يجب
ان لا يموت اي طفل من الجوع اي طفل
النقص في تلك الحبوب وفي الزيوت النباتيه
تلك المنتجات تسهم بحصه الاسد من السعرات
الحراريه في البلدان الناميه
لدينا اشخاص باتوا يتارجحون فعليا على
حافه المجاعه
الطحين غير متوفر على الناس ان يبحثوا عنه
في السوق السوداء
تتضاعف الاسعار ليس فقط بسبب ندره المنتج
ولكن ايضا بسبب الزياده الكبيره في اسعار
الوقود
فيما الاجور باقيه على حالها
نتيجه لذلك اسر كثيره ستنام بلا عشاء اذ
ما عاد بامكانها تحمل كلفه الطعام
يخرج الناس الى الشوارع وتضطر الحكومات
الى التدخل
تتدخل الحكومات لمنع ارتفاع اسعار الخبز
وعدم السماح بقيام ما يشبه تلك الثورات
التي ادت قبل اعوام الى ما يعرف بالربيع
العربي
[موسيقى]
اذا كنت تنفق 50% من دخلك على الغذاء ثم
ارتفع سعره 70% فسيدمر ذلك امكانيه حصولك
على الطعام
هل تعتقد ان الربيع العربي كان مشكله ان
الظروف اسوا من ذلك بكثير في العديد من
البلدان حول العالم كلفه الوقود ترتفع
كلفه الغذاء ترتفع وتكاليف الشحن ترتفع
لا شيء يسبب الضيقه والالم العميق اكثر من
انعدام اليقين لديك حول استطاعتك توفير
الطعام لعائلتك واذا فكرت في الامر من
منظور تاريخي فغالبا ما يكون هذا هو السبب
الاساسي للهجره والحروب
[موسيقى]
مؤلمه كالجوع والموت والهجره الجماعيه
وانعدام الامن هناك صله قويه بين ازمه
الغذاء وانعدام الامن العالمي
[موسيقى]
هناك دول منها دول غربيه تنتظر ايضا وصول
الحبوب لتغطيه احتياجاتها الصناعيه وتلبيه
احتياجاتها الخاصه من وجهه نظر العمل
البسيطه
يبدو انه حتى قبل الحرب في اوكرانيا كانت
اسعار الحبوب قد بلغت اعلى مستوى لها منذ
عشر سنوات
ويمكنك
العقود الاجله هي عقود ماليه لتثبيت سعر
الاصل مقدما والالتزام بالبيع او الشراء
في تاريخ متفق عليه بحيث لا ينعكس السعر
الذي يتم تحديده مسبقا في قيام السوق
صممت اسواق الوقود الاجله ليستطيع
المزارعون التحوط من المخاطر لكن شيئا في
هذه الاليه الماليه قد انهار
في عام 2000 قامت الولايات المتحده بتحرير
القواعد المطبقه على المضاربات بحيث اتاحت
مليارات الدولارات بل مئات المليارات من
الدولارات
كثيره على بلوغنا حافه ركود هائل فماذا
يحدث عندما يشعر الناس بانعدام الامن بشان
مكان اموالهم يمكنك وضع اموالك داخل فراش
لكن مع تضخم هائل لن يعود هذا مكانا امنا
لوضع النقود اموالك تصبح اقل قيمه مما
كانت عليه قبل اسبوع او شهر وهناك الكثير
من الاسباب للاعتقاد بان العقود الاجله
لحبوب السلع امنه ويمكنك الاعتماد عليها
سوق العقود الاجله قبل نجوب الحرب في
اوكرانيا وبعده
كثيرون سيخرجون اموالهم من مؤشر الناس
من اجل استثمارها في البورصه السلعيه
كالحبوب وما شابهها
وهذا بالطبع يمكن ان يرفع سعر تلك الحبوب
بدات الاسعار في الارتفاع فسوف يشتري
هؤلاء المزيد من العقود وهذا قد ينتج عنه
ارتفاع بسيط في السعر سيؤدي بدوره الى
ارتفاع اكبر اي انها تشكل في الاساس عوامل
عدم استقرار ولكن من هم المضاربون الذين
لم يروا حبه قمح من قبل و يراهنون على
تجويع العالم من اجل الارباح
[موسيقى]
الحرب في اوكرانيا بالطبع وقبل كل شيء
تشكل انتهاكا جماعيا لحقوق الانسان
على حق العالم في ان لا يشهد مجاعه لكن
العالم بدا يشهدها
ويتوجب عليه ان يفعل شيئا حيال الكارثه
التي تحدث في اوكرانيا
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي هو وكاله الامم
المتحده المعنيه بمكافحه الجوع يوزع
العاملون في البرنامج ملايين الاطنان من
المواد الغذائيه على المحتاجين في عدد
كبير من دول العالم كان البرنامج يشتري
الحبوب الاوكرانيه من اجل اطعام العالم
الثالث اليوم ياتي برنامج الاغذيه العالمي
من اجل انقاذ اوكرانيا وتوزيع المواد
الغذائيه على سكانها احتاج الى 600 مليون
دولار في اوكرانيا وحدها لثلاثه اشهر
اكثر من 14 مليون اوكراني الى مغادره
منازلهم وفقدوا وظائفهم وانكمش الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي بنسبه 45%
الوضع صعب للغايه
بالنسبه لبرنامج الاغذيه العالمي فان 20%
من السكان معرضون لخطر انعدام الامن
الغذائي بحلول نهايه اكتوبر 2022 وزع
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي اكثر من خمسه
ملايين حصه غذائيه على المواطنين
الاوكرانيين
الناس يموتون المدنيون يموتون انها ماساه
حقيقيه وهي النتيجه الافضل لهذه الحرب كيف
حدث هذا
لكي نفهم علينا ان نذهب الى قلب اوكرانيا
الى حولها المزروعه الممتده بلا نهايه
ثروه اوكرانيا هي تربتها
هذه التربه السوداء الاوكرانيه الشهيره
افضل تربه في العالم
هي خصبه للغايه يسمونها تربه الذهب الاسود
هذه التربه تسمى تشيرنوزن اوكرانيا تحوي
حوالي 30% منها وربما نحن الان ننظر الى
احد الاسباب الكامنه وراء الحرب اليوم هذه
الحقول بلا زرع والمزارع مهجوره وعلى
جانبي الطريق يتراكم حطام السيارات
هذه هي المنظومه الحيويه للزراعه
الاوكرانيه صوامع الغلال الضخمه التي
تختزن الحصاد الجاهزه للتصدير الى جميع
انحاء العالم
[موسيقى]
قبل الرابع والعشرين من فبراير 2022 كانت
سعتنا التخزينيه حوالي 75 مليون طن من
الحبوب تم تدمير حوالي خمسه ملايين طن
بسبب الاعمال العسكريه
هناك ايضا مقاطع فيديو تظهر عدد الصواريخ
التي اصابت محيط الصوامع كما تظهر ايضا
اشكال الصواريخ التي يمكن رؤيتها بوضوح في
الصوره
[موسيقى]
خلال الاسابيع الاولى من الحرب ضربت سلاسل
لوجستيات التوريد داخل اوكرانيا مثل تسليم
المواد الخام اللازمه لصنع الخبز وتسليم
الطحين بالتوازي مع ذلك كان جليا ان مشكله
التصدير صارت من الاولويات سنمر
وفي النهايه اغلقت موانئ البحر الاسود ولم
يعد في امكانيه اوكرانيا تصدير الحبوب
الان حتى لو تم نقل الغمام فان المخازن
المحليه مليئه بالحبوب وقد اضيف اليها
حصاد العام الماضي بانتظار تصريف هذا
المخزون ليس لدينا اي مكان اخر لتخزين
الحبوب الجديده
اصحاب الاراضي الزراعيه لا يستطيعون بيع
منتجات العام الماضي
وليس لديهم راس مال تشغيلي لفتره حمله
البدر الربيعيه وهذا يطلق سلسله من
المشاكل الاخرى التي تتراكم مثل كره الثلج
ميناء اوديسا الذي كان احد اهم الموانئ
البحريه في العالم ظل متوقفا عن العمل
لعده اشهر بعد استهدافه بالقصف الروسي
وفقا لاحصائيات خسر الاقتصاد الاوكراني
سته مليارات دولار شهريا بسبب حصار
الموانئ كانت الصوامع مليئه بحصاه العام
2021 ولم يكن هناك مكان لحصاد العام 2022
فماذا كان يفترض بالمزارعين الاوكرانيين
ان يفعلوا
الذين لديهم منشات وقدره ماليه على تخزين
حبوبهم قاموا بذلك اما الاخرون فاخذوا
يبيعون محاصيلهم باسعار زهيده في ظل غياب
اي امل في البدر مره اخرى
[موسيقى]
هل كانت امام الاوكرانيين خيارات اخرى هل
كان من الممكن تصدير الحبوب من دون
استخدام الموانئ على البحر الاسود
بدانا شيئا فشيئا استخدام كافه الامكانات
التي كانت متوفره لنا بشكل فعلي
بصدارتها النقل بقطارات السكك الحديديه
الى حدودنا الغربيه
لكن خط السكه الحديديه تضرر بشده جراء
القصف ثم كانت هناك مشكله لوجسيه اخرى
لاتساع سكه الحديد مختلفا تماما عن معايير
السكك الحديديه الاوروبيه لذلك كان ينبغي
تفريغ اطنان من الحبوب من عرباتها
وتحميلها على قطارات اخرى ذات عربات
متوافقه مع المسارات الاوروبيه مساله
ضعيفه الجدوى من الناحيه العمليه
حتى النقل البري كان مستحيلا من الناحيه
العمليه اليوم على الحدود الغربيه
لاوكرانيا هناك طوابير من الشاحنات لا
نهايه لها تنتظر عبور الحدود
نراوح مكان ناطله اسبوع لا اعرف لماذا
نتحرك ببطء شديد
الوقت المقدر لعبور الحدود حوالي الشهر
[موسيقى]
الموت جوعا موت رهيب يستحضر في ذاكره
الاوكرانيين كلمه لا يريد احد منهم ان
ينطق بها مره اخرى هولودومور
[موسيقى]
انه تذكير لا لبس فيه بالمجاعه التي
شهدتها اوكرانيا في اوائل الثلاثينيات
[موسيقى]
كلمه اوكرانيه مركبه معناها الاباده
بالتجويع هولد تعني الجوع ومور تعني
الاباده
رميت في المبسقه كسره خبز
فخرجها فلاح واكلها بناهم كلمات كتبها
جاريث جونز وهو صحفي من ويلز عانى من
المجاعه الكبرى التي ضربت الاتحاد
السوفيتي عام
1932 و 33
اراد السوفيات الغاء الزراعه الخاصه
استبدالها بمزارع جماعيه كبيره حيث كانت
الاراضي تستخدم لانتاج المزيد من الغذاء
بهدف زياده الصادرات والدعم التصنيع في
البلاد
يخبرنا جاريث جونز بان الفلاحين
الاوكرانيين لم يرغبوا في مغادره اراضيهم
وان السلطات السوفيتيه لم تتوانى عن قمع
الاحتجاجات
استولوا على الحقول واخذوا المحاصيل
والحيوانات ولم يتركوا للفلاحين ما
ياكلونه
طوال اسبوع ونصف لم نتناول غير الملح
والماء
قبل اقل من شهر هدمت السلطات الروسيه نصبا
تذكريا للمجاعه الكبرى في ماريوبول
وبعد اقل من قرن من الزمن تواجه اوكرانيا
الغنيه ماساه اخرى تتجدد فيها ازمه الغذاء
حول العالم والذي ينتظر رفع الحصار عن
موانئها على البحر الاسود
حصلت التحرك من جانب العالم باسره باتجاه
الطرفين للتوصل الى حل
[موسيقى]
اسرائيل
يجب الاعتراف بان الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان قد لعب دورا لم يلعبه الاخرون
اردوغان يستغل هذا الموقع الجيوسياسي
لبلاده بشكل جيد للغايه ويضعها في قلب
صوره تثير الاهتمام
[موسيقى]
حافظ التركيه وبكل حنكه على موقعها بين
الجانبين هي تتواصل مع موسكو ويتحدث
اردوغان مع بوتين في الوقت ذاته يتحدث
الزعيم التركي مع كييف ويوفر لهم الطائرات
بدون طيار التي كانت مدهشه وفعاله في
المرحله الاولى من الحرب لمواجهه الحجمات
الروسيه في اوكرانيا
وقعت الاتفاقيه في اسطنبول في 22 من يوليو
2022 فاستعاد السفن الشحن نشاطها لتصدير
الحبوب الاوكرانيه
كانت هناك تنتظر الخروج بحمولتها من
الحبوب
بعد ذلك بدايه النهايه لهذه الازمه
الكبيره ولكن هل نحن متاكدون من ذلك
بعد يوم واحد من توقيع الاتفاقيه استهدف
ميناء اوديسا بقصف صاروخيه
حاليا هناك حوالي 20 مليون طن من الحبوب
محاصره في مكانها
تحتاج الى نقل تلك الحبوب لانها منتج سريع
التلف لا يمكن تركه في عنابر الشحن
الداخلي للسفن
تنص اتفاقيه فتح الموانئ على سلسله من
الضوابط التي تؤدي الى اطاله الوقت
المستغرق لتصدير الحبوب في اغسطس تم تصدير
مليون و500 الف طن من الحبوب
اعتبارا من الثلاثين من اكتوبر خرجت اكثر
من 400 سفينه من الموانئ الاوكرانيه على
البحر الاسود بحموله اجماليه قدرها تسعه
ملايين وسبعمائه الف طن من المنتجات
الزراعيه
كل هذا سيعتمد ايضا على مسار الحرب لذا من
الصعب اطلاق التوقعات
لكن الامر الذي لا يصدق كان وجهه السفن
المحمله بالحبوب التي غادرت الموانئ
الاوكرانيه بدا من الرابع عشر من سبتمبر
توجه 27% من السفن الى دول العالم الثالث
وسبعه واربعون في المئه الى البلدان
الاكثر ثراء فيما بلغت الصادرات الى لبنان
والصومال واحدا في المئه فقط
في الاسواق الحره تذهب الصادرات الى مقدم
السعر الاعلى في المزاد واذا كانت البلدان
الثريه تنافس فهذا يعني ان البلدان
الفقيره ستكون الخاسره
ويضاف الى ذلك مشكله الاسمده تعت
مد الحديث كثيرا على الوقود الاحفوري
تحديدا الاسمده
الاسمده القائمه على النيتروجين منتج
ثانوي لهذا الغاز الطبيعي والاسمده
النيتروجينيه المستورده من روسيا مساهم
كبير ومهم في انتاجيه المحاصيل في كافه
البلدان المتقدمه بل وحتى الدول الاقل
نموا تعتمد على هذه الاسمده
ارتفعت اسعار الاسمده بشكل كبير وعجز
الكثير من البلدان الفقيره عن شرائها
بسبب العقوبات اجزاء كثيره من العالم
والتي كانت تحصل على الاسمده النيتروجينيه
من روسيا لم تعد تحصل عليها لذلك حتى مجرد
الشك في احتمال عدم توفر هذا المنتج جعل
العديد من المزارعين اما يقللون من اجمالي
مساحاتهم المزروعه هذا العام او يزرعون
باسلوب تناوب المحاصيل حيث توجهوا الى
الزراعات الاقل استهلاكا للاسمده
النيتروجينيه
اقل حصاد اقل
ولكن الامر لا يتوقف عند هذا الحد
قد يدفع هذا في اتجاه العوده الى بعض
الزراعه غير المشروعه
مثال على ذلك في كولومبيا حيث تزدهر زراعه
البن يزرع الناس ايضا الكثير من نبته
الكوكا غير المشروعه هوكا
[موسيقى]
البن يحتاج الى تسميد مكثف بخلاف الكوكا
تؤدي كلفه الاسمده الى تفاقم الازمه
العالميه من خلال التاثير على المحاصيل
الزراعيه ولكن في اوكرانيا هناك ايضا
تهديد رهيب اخر للمحاصيل المستقبليه
[موسيقى]
في الماضي عمدت الجيوش خلال الحروب الى
تسميم الابار لارغام خصومها على الاستسلام
وهذا هو الحال اليوم لم يتغير شيء
[موسيقى]
في حال اصاب صاروخ مفاعل نوويا في محطه
فما الضرر الذي قد يلحق بالبيئه والمحاصيل
المستقبليه
من الواضح ان كارثه نوويه من مثل حادث في
المحطه او استخدام مثل هذه الاسلحه
سيؤديان ضمن جمله من الامور الى كارثه
بيئيه عالميه
اليوم تستخدم الجيوش اسلحه فتاكه مثل رصاص
اليورانيوم المنضب لكنها ايضا اسلحه رهيبه
من حيث تلويثها التربه والمياه الجوفيه
لكن من الناحيه البيئيه فالارض ملوثه طبعا
بجميع انواع المواد التي تخلفها الاسلحه
بما فيها القذائف هو الصواريخ
هذا سيؤدي الى اضرار من حيث المده الزمنيه
ستحتاج سنوات من الانتظار قبل ان تزرع
محصولا مره اخرى في ارض تضررت بهذه
الطريقه اذا كانت روسيا تريد ضم الاراضي
الاوكرانيه لاهميتها الزراعيه فمن مصلحتها
عدم التلويثها بشيء سيحتاج خروجه منها الى
سنوات
[موسيقى]
تغير المناخ جائحه كوفي 19 الحروب
المضاربات الماليه ما هي الاسباب الاخرى
التي تدفع عالمنا نحو الجوع
[موسيقى]
مليار شخص يعانون من السمنه المفرطه
ومليار اخر يعانون من انعدام الامن
الغذائي
انتاج هذا العام من الغذاء يكفي العالم
لكن الناس لا يملكون ثمنه حسب الراي
الشائع فان الثلث الطعام يهدر يتم اهدار
931 مليون طن من الطعام كل عام كانك تلقي
بحموله ثلاثه وعشرين مليون شاحنه من
الطعام في القمامه كل عام يبلغ متوسط ما
يهدره كل شخص من الطعام 121 كلغ في وقت
يموت اخرون من الجوع
اظن ان الاعتقاد الامريكي بان الاكبر هو
الافضل قد تسلل الى اجزاء اخرى من العالم
لم يسبق لها ان عانت من مشكلات في الوزن
مثل امريكا الجنوبيه وامريكا اللاتينيه
بشكل عام
لضمان الغذائي مسرف ومضر بالبيئه
تخيل ان ملايين الهكتارات تزرع لانتاج
غذاء سيذهب الى سله المهملات كم عدد
الاشخاص الذين كان بالامكان انقاذهم ماذا
يمكننا ان نفعل لدحر هذا الجوع
[موسيقى]
التخفيض في هدر الطعام واستعمال
التكنولوجيا سواء من خلال تطبيقات الهاتف
او من خلال العمل المشترك للحكومات لنقل
الفائض من الطعام من موقع الى اخر
والانتقال من الزراعه الترابيه التقليديه
الى زراعه عموديه داخليه اكثر حضريه
وتعزيز التعاون بين مخازن البقاله
والمزارعين وسوف تقلل من الهدر الى حد
كبير اذا بدات تطبخ لنفسك بطرق متنوعه
يمكننا الانتقال من نظام غذائي قائم على
البروتين الحيواني الى بديل اكثر مراعاه
للكوكب
يجب ان يحصل اصلاح سياسي جاد وتغيير هيكلي
لتحويل اعداد كبيره من الاراضي المستخدمه
حاليا لزراعه علف الحيوانات الى اراضي
تزرع فيها نباتات سياكلها البشر في منزكنه
لا يكون اي حل نتوصل اليه كافيا فمنذ فجر
البش ريه كانت الحرب اكبر مسبب للجوع كتلك
التي تدور راحها الان في اوكرانيا
علينا الان ان نعيش ونعرف كيف نخرج من هذا
الوضع الذي لا تعاني فيه اوكرانيا وحدها
بل العالم باسره
سنبذل كل جهد ممكن وفي حين تقدر ثروه
الكوكب اليوم ب 400 تريليون دولار عار
علينا ان نترك اي طفل يموت جوعا عار علينا
[موسيقى]